okay good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome tonight's planning committee
meeting my name is Peter Richards and I
will be chairing the meeting this
evening
um some housekeeping if I can to start
with please um we're not expecting a
fire alarm so if one does go off run
um follow us in an orderly fashion to
the car park over the road we will need
to check your names off against the
entry list to make sure that everyone's
got out the building safely before we
send you on your Merry Little way
um your mobile phones I'm assuming
everyone's got one um if you could at
the very least turn them silent uh
preferably off I don't mind people using
the provider they don't disturb the flow
and running of this meeting so off would
be preferable silent as a minimum please
um this evening's meeting as I'm sure
you'll know is being recorded and live
streamed
um we will be it is a meeting in public
not a public meeting so only those
people that are registered to speak will
be permitted to do so at the appropriate
time I'll call you forward to one of the
four speakers or microphones in front of
us the button on the right hand side
will turn the microphone on and you will
be able to be heard and speak
um
we will you will have a certain amount
of minutes I will give you those at the
appropriate time typically it's three
minutes and I will give you a 30 second
warning at which point you'll hear this
noise
and you'll be able to carry on
um okay let's do some introductions so
to my far right we have Kira Keller who
is our committee Services representative
to my immediate right we have Sue
Mullins who is our solicitor and our
planners are Ryan Keith Neil Hamstead
and our planning manager is Dale Barco
to my left Dale I believe you've got a
statement to make yes thank you chairman
I'm planning committee manager tonight
and my role is to Aid members in the
decision making thank you fabulous thank
you very much um let's dive into the
agenda do we have any apologies for
absence please Kira yes we have
apologies from counselor Eden with
counselor protector
again thank you very much welcome
council president uh do we have any
disclosures of Interest please members
Council Mills
thanks Mr chairman um on
um agenda four on the uh so item four on
the agenda for shots where I'll be
stepping off that Mr chairman
um on application five on the agenda
Jaguar Land Rover I am the county
councilor for Gayden
um I haven't entered into any discussion
about this but I did go on a site visit
uh with Neil but um
I come here with an open mind and I feel
I can sit on the
on the panelist Jim thank you lovely
thank you very much anyone else
no okay
um minutes is everyone happy with the
minutes from the 8th of February as
presented
I'm seeing a lot of nodding so I'm gonna
assume everyone's happy yeah okay lovely
stuff right let's move to our first
application then which is application
reference
2203114 ful and uh
2203115 LBC the mount in Shotwell our
presenting opposite is Reiner Keith Ryan
over to you
thank you chairman
the application was deferred
at the 8th of February 2023 committee to
allow members site visit
which has taken place on the 17th of
February 2023
the application is denoted by the black
dot on the map
the mount is the grade 2 listed building
positioned centrally within the village
of shortswell and its Conservation Area
surrounded by several other listed
buildings
yeah
the proposals of alterations and
extensions to existing ancillary
outbuildings to form new home office gym
store and garaging
on the plan
on view now blue is retained and red is
new or altered built form
this is a view
looking East with the new pitch roof
over existing structure
in the foreground and a new home office
behind it
this is a view looking East on Chapel
Lane
with home home office to the rice
new roof to outbuilding on the left hand
side
this is looking East on Chapel Lane the
alterations to existing garage and
building up of the Eastern corner of the
site
can also be seen
this is looking down Chapel Lane with
the application site to the left hand
side and the existing built form in view
as well
this is on the Eastern corner of Chapel
Lane looking up
Chapel Lane and looking down
the window to the Gable end of the old
chapel is shown on the right hand side
it will see some loss of daylight as
part of the application
this is looking South towards the
application site and again
the old chapel on the left with the
second window of free
serving a bedroom scene here as well
last this is looking east of Chapel Lane
the application site is on the right
hand side the old farmhouse is to the
immediate rear
and The Boundary Water Fairview on the
left hand side
daylight diagram showing the 45 degree
which is broken by the development
and the 25 degree
line which is not broken
this is taken from the window on the
Gable end of the old chapel
this is received following the member
site visit on the 17th of February
the officer recommendation is to approve
the full application and Grant the LBC
application
finally please refer to the update
sheets for additional items received
since the previous committee
thank you very much chairman
Ryan thank you very much indeed let's
call our first Speaker of the evening
who is a Val Ingram of shotswell Parish
Council
good evening this is Ingram
as I said before you will have three
minutes when your sat come from ready to
go if you press the button on the right
hand side the it should go red and you
will be able to be heard I will give you
the little Pinger at 30 seconds to go
um otherwise when you're ready the
floor's yours
we will be bringing them up shortly
um will you give us a nod when you want
them moving on if you don't mind
or do you just want us to scroll through
gradually
no problem at all right if you could
scroll through as we go through that'd
be great otherwise when you're ready if
you press the button floors yours
firstly mayor thank you for taking the
time to come to shots while it was
greatly appreciated
that said disappointingly I'm giving to
understand that a different
representative from the applicant's
agent joined you and regressively the
case officer doesn't appear to have made
introductions to Residents before
entering their properties I hope now
that you have had the opportunity to
visit our village you can fully
appreciate and evaluate the narrowness
and steepness of the lanes and perhaps
acknowledge our residents concerns
particularly in view of aspects of
overshadowing from these proposed
double-story buildings and the close
proximity to their respective homes and
would no doubt have noted the height
variances of the various properties as
they Cascade down the lane not
forgetting to appreciate the size and
beauty of the mount itself which was
listed in 1987. also perhaps recognizing
that these new buildings in the not too
existent future may serve an entirely
different purpose
we note the agent made reference to
screening by the trees in our report
Warwickshire County Council has already
been granted permission to remove both
the trees shown in the photograph and
given the Verge is not in the
applicant's ownership planting to soften
the building isn't within their gift
have a listen to your last planning
meeting I draw a parallel with a listed
property at warmington and the fact that
this proposal is not going to be
subservient to the main building as it
will completely obliterate the view of
the principal building from the lane and
other listed properties damaging into
visibility in particular from the grade
two Star Church and what is extensively
the oldest part of the settlement in the
warmington application it is noted that
the conservation Architects sought the
advice of the Society of the protection
of ancient buildings as part of the
building was to be demolished but
doesn't appear to have done so in this
instance which again is perplexing I
once again draw your attention to the
case officer report which in essence
appears to be a virtual copy and paste
of the agent's rebuttal and as such
inspires no confidence this has been
independently assessed the case
officer's report is confirmed by the
conservation of Zoom self as crucial in
determining the effect of on the street
scene and the proposal's impact on other
Heritage buildings within the
conservation settlement I'm sorry if I
focused on procedure but given the
requests withdraw our application twice
by the case officer and the attempt to
void our objections by the ward member I
feel the committee needs to be aware of
what appears to be serious shortcomings
in the assessment and therefore the
recommendation of the case officer
shortswool is a pretty historical
conservation Village packed with
character and blessed for many listed
buildings coupled with some of the
narrowest lanes in the county making it
particularly quirky it deserves to be
protected for everyone's enjoyment our
feeling is this overbearing development
will be by the scale in its location
create a domineering element which would
compete with it and detract from the
listed building's significance affecting
the process the quiet enjoyment of
neighboring homes with loss of light
privacy and potential glare from solar
panels with therefore ask the committee
to please reject the application in its
current form
Miss Ingram thank you very much for that
spot on your time members do we have any
questions from Miss Ingram please
no in that case Michigan thank you very
much for your time contribution this
evening
okay let's call forward our next speaker
who is Miss Charmaine Herridge
good evening and welcome back
I believe we have two photos from you so
we'll bring those oh in fact they're
already up uh Ryan's well ahead of me
um so in the same way as before you'll
have three minutes I'll give you a 30
second warning by pressing our little
noisy button when you're ready and
settled the floor is yours
thank you chair for the current
application to move forward would seem
to depend on your agreement that the
proposed buildings at the mount replaces
a group of redundant Farm sheds which
were demolished over two generations ago
they had very shallow tin roofs and bear
no resemblance to the fault-like
structure being suggested
if you agree to this proposal today
you're effectively stating that the 7.5
meters between our property the old
chapel as you can see on the photograph
and the new development is acceptable
simply because it replaces ramstrackle
buildings demolish decades ago
quite apart from the ludicrous nature of
that statement 50 years ago the chapel
was a place of worship but for the last
25 years it's been our house with
habitable rooms on the first floor which
would be directly overlooked by the
windows in the proposed development
seven and a half meters away from our
upstairs window
um you'll remember and if you look at
where the shadow is on this particular
photograph it was taken very roughly the
same time of day as when the site visit
occurred simply a month earlier
and it shows the uh where the bedroom is
it's the only south facing window in the
house it's used as a bedroom but also a
sitting room and a study during the day
so if you imagine a line running
horizontally on that photograph from the
shadow you can see immediately how the
light would be blocked if you'd go back
to the first photographer okay please
continuing up this Lane up a steep hill
and round to the right brings us between
the new proposed development which would
be about 10 to 12 meters away from
Fairview
another listed building across the line
where light would be blocked from their
patio and kitchen Diner the existing
Tool Shed which would practically double
its existing height to around about five
meters would stand just 10 to 12 meters
away from the extension Windows of the
old farmhouse yet another listed
building which has been specifically
extended by the current owners in order
to increase light into the house
whilst we wouldn't dream of telling our
neighbors or trying to tell our
neighbors what they should or shouldn't
do with their own home there's
definitely a lack of comprehension on
behalf of most people in the village who
can't understand why a home gym a double
home office a kitchen and a toilet can't
be encompassed within the existing
five-bedroomed seven reception beautiful
listed building which already exists
rather than rather than the imposing
claustrophobic and overbearing impact
that because of the massing issue the
proposed new building would have on the
lane and its occupants
the mount part 17th century as I'm sure
you know currently remains just as it
was when it was listed in 1987 and is at
the heart of this conservation Village
opposite to Invisible from our grade 2
stylistic Church we're reminded of you
quoting the 1990 listed buildings acts
councilor Harvey when you talked about
the requirement to pay special attention
to preserving or enhancing the character
or appearance of the area
I'm going to have to ask you to wrap up
now that is your time thank you very
much can I finish the sentence thank you
thank you um I suggest that you wouldn't
be paying that special attention should
the plans be given approval you'd be
letting down the future inhabitants of
the village and thank you
thank you very much indeed members do we
have any questions from Miss Heritage
please Council Parry
thank you and good evening
um I just wonder whether you can confirm
you talk about the first floor bedroom
which you use as a sitting room and the
south facing window are there any other
windows
to that particular room absolutely which
face
um are they which which way do they face
exactly
um I'm really glad you asked me that
because I was desperate to fit that bit
in but couldn't in the time
um it's really interesting the way that
this the chapel as those people who came
and came into the bedroom it was like
the jokes of the elephants in the mini
by the time had finished
um but we've got one east facing and one
west facing the east facing faces
directly into the bank going upwards to
the next door neighbor to the old
vicarage so there's very very little
light comes in from that side the other
one we get beautiful sunsets but nothing
enjoying the day so there's an East
there's a West there's this South one
but not really very much quality like
through those two
thank you councilor Curtis
councilor Perry asked my precise
question thank you
anyone else
no in that case massage thank you very
much for your time contribution this
evening
okay let's call our final speaker on
this item who is Miss Swan our agent and
I believe we'll be joined by Mr ingerson
who is our applicant
good evening to you both and welcome
when you are settled and comfortable on
this one you'll have six minutes again
I'll give you a 30 second warning in the
same way as before whenever you're
comfortable and ready to go the floor's
yours
could you put your microphone on for me
please
I'm hoping to limit it to five and a
half minutes and the applicant himself
wishes to have a short 30-minute
speaking slot 30 minutes 30 minutes 30
seconds good Lord
[Laughter]
okay so do you want me to give you your
uh time warning at five minutes I know
you've got 30 seconds to go yeah fine
we'll do uh when you're ready floors
yours
I'm just gonna set a timer as well just
so I can keep an eye on her
foreign
okay
thank you as we highlighted at the last
meeting Mr ingerson has lived at the
mount for 31 years and is acutely aware
of conservationary constraints and the
presence of surrounding listed buildings
the proposals before you have been
designed to take account of these
Heritage issues and potential neighbor
impacts the first photo on the screen
now shows the center of the village in
about 1960 with the mount visible in the
top left-hand part of that image
next photo is a zoomed in view of the
mount showing the range of barns in the
corner of the site you can see how high
the walls are in that image and the
scale of pitched roof elements the barns
extended closer to the house than the
current garage building does and
included a section of building to the
left of where the current access Drive
is now located
the current garage and Boundary walls
that you saw during the site visit are
the remains of these barns these
buildings were in a dangerous state by
1970 and part of one Barn had collapsed
into the road permission was given for
the roofs and some walls to be removed
the garage and the current boundary
walls were created from the elements
that retained with permission also given
to build up the current missing section
of wall in the corner of the site
we looked at the old planning
application for the garage and found a
letter that shows that the
partial removal of the buildings was
carried out for structural reasons not
to let light into the lane as stated by
the parish council at the last committee
meeting we feel it's important to
correct that statement the current case
officer has a copy of this letter
referring to the structural issues
affecting the original barns next slide
please moving on to what's proposed the
image on the left shows the back wall of
the existing garage facing the old
chapel with the proposed elevation on
the right the height of the new building
would be exactly the same as the
existing garage next slide please
on the elevation facing Fairview the
pitched roof would only extend along
part of the building with a flat roof
section with a lower Eaves height
towards the corner Beyond this this
section of wall would be lower than
existed within the historic barns and
would be built using local Stone the
solar panels on the roof would not be
visible from the road
you probably noted during the site visit
that the current garage roof is in a
very poor State and the wall along the
southern boundary has been damaged by
the roots of the large tree that used to
be within the highway Verge the
proposals would resolve these structural
problems and also provide a safe means
of enclosure to the inside corner of the
site which is currently open as you saw
on site with a steep drop down to the
road the proposed home office and
fitness room would be for ancillary use
only and the applicant is happy to
accept a condition controlling the use
going forward
the applicant approached the
conservation officer for pre-app advice
as far back as 2019 and amended the
design in line with the advice received
the conservation officer raises no
objection to the current application on
either Conservation Area or list of
building grounds
the house was listed after the original
barns were removed in the early 70s and
were fully aware that the surrounding
area has changed to some extent since
demolition occurred Mr ingerson is not
arguing that a reinstatement at a
similar scale would be appropriate and
he isn't seeking to replicate the
original barns the scheme before you is
significantly smaller than what was
there historically with the majority of
the original pitched roof sections
entirely absent the proposals would be a
modern variation of the original form of
buildings enclosing this side of the
site which would visually improve its
current neglected appearance next slide
please
The Village contains many examples of
buildings positioned close to narrow
Village Lanes including the two
properties immediately uphill from the
mount and you would have walked past
those on your visit
there are full these are full two-story
buildings with pitched roofs the
proposed development would be set back
from The Verge with the tallest element
measuring just six meters from ground
level to roof Ridge with the majority of
buildings not having a pitch roof at all
next slide please
the site-6 sits significantly lower than
the two neighboring houses to the West
with the gardens in between as you can
see in the photograph this ensures that
the amenity of these neighbors is
safeguarded next slide please
the site's well over 10 meters away and
to the Northeast side of Fairview with a
tree within the highway Verge in between
fairview's kitchen at this end of the
building is dual aspect with two windows
and a half glazed door providing light
the development would not breach any
planning guidelines in terms of impact
on this neighbor
next slide please
the building opposite the old chapel has
been specifically designed with a flat
roof to reduce the impact on this
property the council's 45-25 degree test
to assess impacts on light
it was applied by the applicant when
designing the proposals the new
structure is well below the key 25
degree line as you can see there
measured from the site center of the
first floor bedroom window this bedroom
has two further Windows one on each side
of the property so benefits from
additional sources of light and sunlight
there's no ground floor window on this
side of the chapel overall the
development would be a much reduced
version of an historic building layout
which meets council's technical
standards in terms of impacts on
neighbors resolves current structural
problems and would provide the property
with more flexible living space we would
therefore ask that you approve the
applications which have the support of
conservation and planning offices and
the ward member thank you chairman
thank you Mr Anderson if you want to
carry on right someone once stated that
if you tell me your truth I'll tell you
mine Society therefore devised rules
regulations and laws to determine
the veracity of different claims
thus to differentiate between Vivid
assertions exaggerations and lies
these lies are to oppose the facts our
application has consistently been based
on the relevant planning criteria
we can do no more thank you very much
spot on time there as well thank you
very much to you both members do we have
any questions do our agent or our
applicant
I think councilor Harvey was just in
first
a question for Mrs Swan
um the photograph you showed of the two
houses in Chapel Lane to demonstrate how
close they were
would I be writing thinking those houses
were constructed before current planning
legislation was put into effect
a clearly historic structures within the
Conservation Area
but are typical of layouts within the
village as a whole in that Central core
area
Council Curtis please
thank you chair
um could we go back to the second
picture that Mrs Swan showed
it was the it was the zoom in of the
sort of
the The Wider area
ah
that's it yes thank you very much
um
it I it's quite difficult to see but to
me
um it looks as though the the roof
particularly where we can see the sort
of rusting corrugated iron
that looks as though it is I'm not sure
the technical term
uh not a full pitched roof but a a sort
of sloping roof would that be correct
could you pop your microphone on when
you respond please thank you
I don't know if Mr ingerson wants to
answer here it is a pitched roof yes my
question is is it that shape pitched
roof or just a single angle
all right you can follow the same line
okay
um
it looks as though it's somewhat lower
than the proposed height of the new
development I was just trying trying to
establish what the original roof height
may have been but it's probably not
possible sorry thank you
no problem any other questions cancel
the Crump
could is working yeah just very briefly
um the parish council mentioned about
the shielding
um and and the trees that potentially
going to be cut down just wondered what
um shielding and planting you'd got in
if that's not the case how would you
replace that and what what type of
planting you'd have please
a very large tree has recently been
removed by the County Council within the
highway Verge The Verge itself is
outside Mr ingerson's ownership
um so obviously we don't have the right
to to plant within that area there
there's no proposal as well I'm aware to
remove the tree that Still Remains
within that Verge
any other questions members councilor
Adam please
uh just briefly with regards to the um
excuse me the diagram that showed the
angles uh I know
I noticed that you had the flat roofed
section shown on that but um obviously
there will be
part of the development further up the
hill as an assessment been carried out
as to where that will sit within the
angles
foreign
that's quite some distance up the hill
and is well clear of the the 25 degree
line as well
councilor Parry please
thank you chair
good evening you highlighted during your
presentation that the proposed new
building is smaller than the than what
was historically present could you just
um give a bit more detail in terms of
how much smaller it was maybe I just
miss misheard that you might well
have mentioned it in your presentation
I think probably one of Ryan's
plan showing the the red and the blue is
what you need to have regard to
um
there used to be an additional length of
building beyond the garage between the
the end of the garage and the
and the dwelling
it's
not visible on that that plan
mm-hmm
but that's now laid out as an area of
planting within the garden and equally
to the left of the main entrance to the
site which is the the area shown
um there's a blue line
to the left of the the gate
um that used to have a building with a
pitch drove over it and there's no plan
to actually install any form of
structure behind that section of
retained wall
okay so the first piece of additional
building is going off the top of the
screen in that image
okay and any other questions members
no in that case to both of you thank you
very much your time contribution this
evening
all right we have no more speakers on
this item so we'll move now to points of
clarification to our officers has anyone
got anything they would like clarifying
councilor Kendall first please so it's
not actually a point of clarification
it's just a declaration of interest it's
the same one from last time that the
speaker for the parish council is known
to me but it uh I can come to the
meeting with an open mind as far as I'm
concerned apologies for not bringing it
up earlier that's quite all right
Council pair together please yeah can
you
um the officer can confirm whether in
relation to the old chapel the 45 degree
um line that has been satisfied or is
them is there breached
the 45 degree
set of line with the bedroom with a
habitable room yeah so
it is within the 45 degree so there is a
breach in that regard okay
um and then the secondary test which we
do which is a 25 degree line is then not
breached by the development
chairman I think it's important that
members understand that the test is the
45 25 test it's a composite test uh
failure of one part of the test doesn't
mean you fail the test you need to fail
both parts to fail the test thank you
okay thank you any other points for
clarifying Council purse together again
but would he mean that is there a loss
of light in the bedroom resulting from
the
um
the proposed building
so it has been acknowledged within our
assessment that there would be a level
of loss of light you can't get away from
that but our assessment is there is no
breach of the 25 and we assess that
given
um
the
the relationship that it would not lead
to a significant level of loss of light
to Warrant refusal in that regard
Council Harvey please um
am I right in thinking that this
proposal involves the creation of a war
which is five meters high
it's question one
simple question but my second question
more important question is are there any
other examples of boundary Walls Within
the conservation area of that height and
is so
or to what extent physical length are
these five meter high walls
and just in regards to the height are
you referring on the
um
the elevation towards the old chapel
where Lee garage is at the moment and
the building up of that corner
that's correct that corner
yeah so in that regard the total height
I have a measurement from the top of
the garage as it is now to
uh Road level at 8.1 meters
the
um
and then from the garage to
the bottom of the garage as it is is 5.2
meters and that is the same for the
building up of the corner of that
eastern wall
in regards to your point uh in regards
to Walls Within the Conservation Area
I don't have that information but what I
can say to you
as mentioned within the officer report
um
is
the village of Shotwell is defined as
much by its balls hedgerows and narrow
Lanes as it is by its buildings
um
the last point I would just make to you
is that the mount does lie within the
church area a middle Lane character area
which is defined by
steep topography bounded by Banks walls
and foliage
so it's a it's a part of the character
of the conservation area in this
in this position
thank you just for clarity that's on
page 10 of your report bottom paragraph
counselor Perry next please
thank you
um
officers I wonder where the sorry it's a
it's a height differential again Ryan
um I wonder if you have the differential
height between the historical pitched
roof and the proposed new pitched roof
just for clarity and I I think it might
be in there but just be really helpful
just to have confirmation of that
done
if I understand councilor parry's
question correctly she's referring to
the photograph that Mrs Swan showed at
the beginning of her presentation with
the pitched roof on it
and do we have uh any figures relating
that to the proposal and the answer is
simply no we don't have any records
showing what height those buildings were
at the time the assessment obviously is
the impact that this development will
have relative to its current form that's
fine thank you
councilor Curtis please
thank you I'm not sure whether this is a
question for clarification or a point
for debate
um but it was and this is Ingram's
second photo
if it's possible to bring that up the
showing the views across
to the main house
what impact the proposed Ridge height
would have on that view so
is that for clarification or a point for
debate later
uh yeah I think it's a bit of both to be
honest with you what we can do is bring
up the photo so you can have a look
um the impact is an assessment and yours
decision maker can make your own
assessment on the impact I think so I
think we'll just show the photo for now
so we're looking at the photo and my
question is
can we show with the cursor
on that photo where the new Ridge height
would be is that a reasonable question
for clarification Jay yep I think you
can have a rough idea I think
and bear in mind it will be a rough idea
it's not going to be precise absolutely
I've lost the cursor
oh yeah
well Ryan tries to work the answer out
to this question councilor Curtis I I
think it's fair to say
that it may not be a very helpful in
your decision making but we'll learn
we'll give you the best guess we can
thank you
excuse me
so just on the left hand side here is
where the start of the ridge would so
this the eaves would be for the pitch
roof part
and then it would obviously
um come up
probably about here across but bear in
mind that obviously that's not straight
up it's pitched away from
um the but the the the new Ridge height
is as I understand from the report and
the measurements given
it is the same again as the pillar High
the existing pillar that is correct
isn't it thank you thank you Chad
Council Crump please just follow you
briefly um become the impact on the
neighbor's property in terms of light
diminution
as the 45 degree rules breached but not
the 25
that reduces either the weight we can
give for a refusal in terms of impact on
neighbors is that fair
foreign as the 45-25 degree I I've told
members many times in the past I'm sure
that the 45-25 degree test is of limited
value whether it passes it or not but it
is a guide
and in this instance the guide is that
it passes it
um nevertheless as you saw from the
photograph of Mrs Herridge there will be
a time when that window in that Gable
uh will be shaded when it currently
isn't what members have to assess is
whether the additional shading of that
window at some times of day at some
times of year bearing in mind that there
are at least two other wind there are
two other windows to the room whether
that amount of additional shading will
be so great
as to justify refusing the application
and you can obviously see the assessment
that officers have made in your report
thank you
okay any more points of clarification
before we move into the base
no let's go into the debate who would
like to kick us off
don't jump at once I'm going to point
there we are cancer curses is in good
man okay thank you chair
um
the applicant's agent has made
um considerable play of the fact that
the proposed new build if you like is
significantly smaller
than the previous
um
but I think and in some respects I'm
sure that is absolutely accurate in that
in as much as one of the previous
buildings nearest the house is not being
rebuilt but I think when we're looking
at the development of The Proposal as a
whole
um significantly smaller I don't think
some of these Ridge Heights
so they certainly don't look
significantly smaller I think they look
significantly larger and given that it's
already been confirmed that there are no
records available of previous Ridge
Heights and I think that statement that
it is significantly small and needs to
be questioned
okay thank you very much councilor
Harvey please
yep
I start off by the on the basis that the
responsibility of this body is as the
decision maker and we have a statutory
responsibility in relation to listed
buildings and the conservation area to
be special regard and special attention
there are two lines in the officer's
report which I will draw attention to on
page 14. I'm satisfied The Proposal
would not unacceptably detract from the
immunities of any neighboring Properties
by way of overlooking overshadowing
overshadowing or overbearing impact
first statement second statement is in
the conclusion I consider the proposals
and The Wider Village Conservation Area
without any harm arising to these
important designed Heritage assets I
have a real problem
because
what we're saying is that the
the case officer has come to an
interpretation of what he thinks the
impact of this develop would be on the
conservation area and he thinks it's
okay I have my severe doubt I think
putting a five meter wall
on that corner is is a significant
imposition on the conservation area's
appearance
and I I hear what the conservation
officer says and he's entitled to his
opinion but he's not the decision maker
I'm part of the body that is of the
decision-making body I have a real
problem and I'm waiting for somebody to
convince me that my concern about the
height of that wall
should be regarded as
um uh not significant to the point where
it would encourage me to to refuse to
vote in favor of refusing this
application so I'll look forward to the
rest of the debate with interest
I I just want to be absolutely clear now
are you making a proposal to refuse or
are you waiting to hear what other
people have to say first
I I'm prepared to wait to hear what
others have to say understood councilor
Perry next please
thank you chair
um first of all I think this is a very
challenging application
um unfortunately I wasn't able to attend
the site visit due to a clash with the
big event I was involved before I went
away however I did drive by the site
this afternoon
um returning from after returning from
holiday because I was Keen to actually
see see the remind myself of shots well
and it's complex
the challenge that I have got is that we
have got
a conservation officer's report
um
advising there's there isn't an issue in
terms of the impact on the Conservation
Area
and they are experts in terms of the
Conservation Area
equally I do have a problem
um particularly when we talked about the
45-25
ruling and there is a breach on the 45
and we have in the conclusion which
councilor Harvey highlighted that
um there wouldn't be any harm arising
from this particular application the
clearly always in any form of
application there is an element of harm
um
and I can understand having driven
through the village
unfortunately it was snowing this
afternoon so I couldn't actually see
there was no sunlight so it was
difficult to orientate where
um where the light was actually coming
from however on the other side of the
the coin we have more than one window
this is a is a double-facing room in
fact it might even be triple facing
because it's it's Southeastern West so
there's there's other light coming in
um however we have a situation where the
proposed development is being presented
as historically smaller than what was
there before so
I'm I'm in a situation where we also
have to think
um
I'm very sympathetic to members of The
Village because I think shots well it
has got its particular character but
then on the other hand
um certainly I feel the the the the
planning age that they have certainly
looked at where they could possibly
minimize impact
um in the village
so I'm actually sitting on the fence at
the moment as well waiting to hear what
others want to say but based on the
conservation officers report I'm more
urring towards in favor of Grant because
of the appeal situation and the strength
and the expertise of the conservation
officer but I shall wait I wish to wait
to hear I'd like to gain a greater
understanding of material planning
reasons to refuse and that's what I'm
struggling with particularly on our
policies the strength of the
conservation area and also the
recommendation of Grant from the
planning officer so I look forward to
hearing what my colleagues around the
table have to say
thank you very much Council Barry
Council Dixon please
thank you chairman
when I look at the screen we're looking
at now and I see the uh the gable roof
on the proposed extension there
I don't see that that has any
detrimental impact on Fairview Cottage
which is obviously the one that has the
patio which could be impacted by by
Shadow I think the separation and the
fact that that pitch roof obviously goes
away I don't see that as as an issue
myself
um when I then link about the old chapel
we obviously on the site visit saw the
shadow we've seen the photograph tonight
of The Shadow
but I think that also indicates that
that current window also gets shadowed
in the current scenario
I.E before any extension and it is a
flat roof extension it's not a pitch
roof at that particular uh
elevation facing the old chapel and the
we are assured that the extension is the
same height as the existing garage
therefore I have to say I don't have any
issue with this application thank you
Jim just to confirm are you making a
proposal to Grant online with the office
of recommendation I would be reminded to
yes I will thank you very much Council
Curtis next please
thank you
um
can we go back to the photo I asked to
see previously please I think it was the
second sorry a bigger pun no it was the
it was Mrs Swan's second
picture I uh no I think one um it was
the view from the when I asked if we
could see where the pitched roof may be
yeah the view from the patio could we
look at that one again please
so
um
so I was in the other group I beg upon
sorry jay
thank you Ryan
from the patio looking across to the
main house
thank you Ryan
I'm sorry councilor Perry
while Ryan the reason I'd like to bring
this up again refers
back to councilor Harley's points on the
top of page 14.
um where the officer the officer report
says the proposal would not unacceptably
detract from the amenities of any
neighboring Properties by way of
overlooking overshadowing or overbearing
impact
and
it's only my subjective View
but I think in in my view regardless of
what the conservation officer says
May disagree with their assessment
and as councilor Harvey's pointed out we
are entitled to come to a different View
I think that Ridge height which will be
the proposed Bridge height
which for half the war the the pillar
and then the main elevated section
is going to be
at approximately the ridge height the
top Ridge height of the main building
I think that does have a really
significant impact
thank you for getting the photo up but
thanks
I mean I I appreciate that that is a
contribution towards the debate I'm
trying to decipher whether or not that
was a proposal it sounds like you're
erroring towards refuse but I haven't
heard any substantive planning reasons
are you going to be proposing refuse and
if you are can you give me some reasons
if you're not I'll move on
I I'm simply going to listen
um but I'm not minded to support at the
moment thank you chair understood
councilor Adam please
thank you sorry I've got to be a bad
throats I'll try and push through
one of the points that the I think it
was the Parish Council made was with
regards to
how the massing of the proposed
made the view from at least certain
external views uh be it from the road or
other other houses
essentially started to block out the
main house that was you know the the
address of the site and therefore it
suggested that it wouldn't be
subservient
now I appreciate that he is a smaller
building to the house is a significant
house but I think it almost touches on
what councilor Curtis was talking about
with the roof was that actually that
massing does
yeah from Road level
um and then around the corner to
increase the kind of impact of the the
development would have on the site at
Large
and only I think it's fair to say that
there's quite a lot of
feeling against this even though there's
clearly a lot of work by the applicant
to make sure that it does suit up
our policies
and that's the one that seems to be
sticking to me along with the the light
impact I completely appreciate the the
um what Dale's saying in regards to the
the rule for for the Angles and that's
kind of why I pride with the with the
applicant as well because on on top of
that the massing from the road I think
that the Gable end will also have an
impact above the flat roof and albeit
that that's not breaching the 25 it
seemed to be minimized slightly by the
diagram
those are my reservations I think the
subservient nature of it
is an interesting thought that the
parish council raised that may be
wanting exploring as a as a a reason to
refuse
um but again I think the applicants have
done a lot of work to try and make this
fit within our policies
from from what I gather
um and and so
like I said I'd like to explore that
before going any further but that
otherwise I think I would have to
support it on the basis that there
aren't any hard hard reasons to refuse
despite my reservations
thank you um I just trying to get this
clear in my head are you you're
you want to explore the subservient
nature of the proposal to the main
building and whether that is a
substantive reason to refuse is that
right
um I'm going to turn to our planning
manager and or officer to give their
view on that if that's right please
it's difficult to know where to start
with the answer to that counselor um
your conservation officer has assessed
that in his view it is subservient or
the word I'd use is subordinate but it
doesn't really matter in his view it is
subservient I think as a matter of fact
these buildings are not of the same
scale as the main house and therefore as
a matter of fact they are subservient
but your concern that longer distance
views
will result in some parts of the
original House the the listed house no
longer being visible
are nevertheless correct
yes that's absolutely right but the
buildings remain subservient they remain
subordinate to the the main house
and it is your planning offices and your
conservation officers view that the uh
that the form and nature of these these
proposed buildings
contribute to the character of The
Village and reflect the character of The
Village rather than jarring and and
um conflicting with it obviously you're
entitled to come to a different
conclusion should you so wish
councilor Perry next please
thank you chair
um
on further consideration
I wished a second
councilor Dixon's proposal to Grant
this is a very difficult and challenging
application but I can't see a
significant material planning reason to
refuse that would stand up to the
planning inspectorate
particularly when we have such a strong
support from our conservation officer
which is backed up by our planning
officer
um
it's it's a very finely balanced
decision we have this evening
and I know that's it is a difficult one
and I am sympathetic with neighbors and
people who live in shots well but we're
here to make the difficult decisions and
I can't see a strong enough material
planning reason so I will therefore
second councilor Dixon's proposal chair
thank you very much councilor Harvey
please I was going to offer to propose a
refusal if it would help procedurally
but if that's not the case I'll I won't
please do it may well change people's
minds we will have to take the proposal
to Grant first as it has been proposed
and seconded but by all means propose an
alternate and if that fails then we move
to yours
okay I would propose refuse
on the grounds of non-compliance with
cs9 and cs20 because the development has
an overbearing impact uh it's it fails
on cs12 because of its scale it's
disproportionate to its setting
and it is uh it it it doesn't comply
with our responsibilities under the
1999-1990 Act 2 uh preserve the
conservation area because of its impact
uh its harmful impact on the
conservation area's appearance and
setting
three reasons
yeah I'm just going to re go over those
three because I only got I think I might
have joined two up
um so first of all cs9 and 20
overbearing uh cs12 disproportionate
it's scalar disproportionate in terms of
its setting and then the conservation
which is the 1990 act and and got you
I've got you three thank you Council
curses I'm very habitable to Second
counselor Harvey's proposal
okay thank you very much okay
does anyone else want to say anything
before we take our first vote which will
be the vote on granting and I'm with
Us's recommendation
note in that case um The Proposal is to
Grant in line with recommendation in
favor of doing so please
five
and those against
six and abstentions
none so that therefore fails so we have
a proposal to refuse
um for the reasons given and let me just
double check that we're happy that
you've got sufficient reasons okay
um I'm going to ask cancer
um Harvey if he wants to add in I'm
assuming it's part of the overbearing
you're particularly referring to the
loss of light to uh the I think the old
chapel over the road is that right or
just general overbearing no I
the overshadowing is a separate point
which I didn't mention but but it is
another reason but but it's the scale of
the of what would appear which I in my
view would have an overbearing impact on
the Conservation Area so we've I'm glad
we've managed to tease out a fourth
reason which we will add to your reason
for refusal cancel the case as I'm
assuming you're happy with that fourth
reason marvelous anyone else got
anything to say before we moved to the
vote
uh the loss of light to the old chapel
foreign
okay right let's have a show of hands
for those in favor of refusing for the
reasons given please
six and those against
just oh blow me four and abstentions
one so committee therefore resolves to
refuse now this is just on the ful
refuse application
2203114ful I'm going to assume we're
going to have the same proposal
councilor Harvey for the LBC
and councilor Curtis you're going to
second that presumably could have a show
of hands to those in favor of refusing
the LBC please
six those against
four abstentions
one committee therefore resolves to
refuse application 2203115lbc
thank you very much indeed um let's move
on to our next application which is
application reference
2203361 ful and that is at Jaguar Land
Rover in Gaiden and our presenting
officer will be Neil hamsters
as soon as you're ready so yeah
okay ladies and gentlemen let me
okay
counselor Crump I appreciate you trying
to support one of our fellow councilors
so I will let that go
um okay members um uh I'm a presenting
officer for the next application which
is Jaguar Land Rover uh in Gayden is
Neil Hempstead Neil when you're ready
over to you
thank you chair
the um the application site is on the
screen marked with the uh with the black
dot
um and the proposal is for a proposed
solar array and grid connection uh
approximately 28 hectares in size with
supporting energy infrastructure and
Associated works with an operational
period for up to 40 years
so just to give a bit more context to
that
so the red line
is the application site
and the um So within this area here
are the where the solar panels are going
to be installed proposed to be installed
with the access going up here to the B4
B4 100 through the existing Jaguar Land
Rover and British motor museum sites
with the underground cable going to an
existing substation
so the proposed installation would have
a rated capacity of Circa 20.1 megawatts
and would provide approximately 40 of
the electricity needs of Jaguar Land
Rover at their Gaiden site
and just to give a context in terms of
the location that's the British motor
museum with the Jaguar Land Rover site
to the north
and the village of Gaiden here to the
South
this is an ecological bum which was
referred to in the um
in the committee report and just to give
members a bit more context in respect of
that so this is the application site
where the
um
solar panels will be installed so
there's four four Fields the upper part
here is proposed to be retained for
agricultural purposes
so access will still be able to be
achieved there
there's the ecological bun that I was
referring to and I've got some further
photographs that will give a bit more
context to that Gaiden to the South
and uh and jaguar Land Rover and the
British motor museum to the north again
you can see the underground cable route
to an existing substation
and the access which we'll be going
through to the b4100
it's worth pointing out some of the
existing hedgerows on the site just
being marked with the with the cursor
which are proposed to be uh re retained
there is some mild very minor loss but
the majority will be into in uh retained
and enhanced as well
so in terms of the layout so the area
which I showed you before with the solar
panels
you can see the the four Fields where
they're proposed to be
installed again the access and the
underground cable routes
you can see some of the internal access
routes which will be required to gain
access to all the areas
um I've got a highest scale of this
which I'll show in a minute but just to
give an understanding there are proposed
to be 24 CCTV cameras installed around
the perimeter of the of the site
five Transformer and substations which
will roughly be one two three four and
five here
there's a storage container which is
proposed to be located in this area here
and there's a number of underground
cables
so just to give a bit more context so
I've just taken an area so to the um to
the corner of the site just just to give
members a bit of a closer version of the
layout so what you can see is some of
the positioning of some of the CCTV
cameras which will be
inward facing and will be subject to a
condition to ensure that that is the
case
you can see some of the existing
Hedgerow here which is to be retained
which I pointed out on the aerial
photograph
some of the internal access roadways the
Transformer substation
there's some inverters as well which are
on the back of some of the um of some of
the solar panels so what I've got next
is some of the these elements which I
refer to in a bit more detail
so this is a sort of typical section
through the um
through the solar panels
um and what you can see is that just
under three meters in height
and they will be in sort of 48 and 24
module arrays
then we have the Transformer substation
which you can see is just over sort of
two meters in height
we have um illustration of the proposed
security fencing which approximately
three meters in height
um
there will be proposed to be some access
routes built into the fence as well
which will be secure by condition
to um to enable access by Wildlife on
the site
so this is the
um customer container cabin container
which will be used for for storage
this is one of the inverters that I was
referring to which is very small in
scale and is is effectively attached to
some of the backs of some of the some of
the solar panels
and this is the um illustration of CCTV
camera
which will be approximately four meters
in height which will be uh collapsible
um
for um for for purposes and maintenance
so
this is an illustration of proposed
Landscaping on the site
um members would notice that this that
the final Landscaping schemes to be
secured by condition
but what what this shows is is
maintaining the existing internal
um hedgerows and enhancing where
possible there is some very minimal
um reduction to to help in terms of
accesses and sort of the main access
into the site there
what what the proposal does does
um intend to do is to enhance where
there are gaps in the existing boundary
treatment
especially along the um the southern
boundary and the main site will be given
over to Wildflower and um and grass seed
as well so that will be the main part of
the the site you can see in there
so just giving members a a feel for for
the appearance of the site at the moment
so the four Fields I I referred to are
are detailed on this on this on this
photograph
that to the South is the um the existing
ecological area with gaid and Beyond
so Jaguar Land Rover in the British
motor museum or just beyond to the north
of the site
you can see the topography as it slopes
down
so in the foreground here we have Field
Four
we have field three in the middle and
that's roughly the highest part of the
site and my next photograph will be
looking down towards the village of
Gayden and the ecological Bund
filled to to the South here and then
field one which effectively it will wrap
around this part here and the crudely
the the access to the site will be will
be over here
so to give an extent of the western
boundary of the site if you can see the
Hedgerow
just there that gives an indication of
the extent of the western part of the
site
and you can see these internal hedgerows
which as I emphasized before to be
retained which which I showed on the um
on the aerial photograph so hopefully
that gives members a context of the uh
of the site
and so looking looking southwards
so behind where this Photograph would
take would be the British motor museum
and
um Jaguar Land Rover
so in the foreground here existing
um agricultural land
where the solar array would be would be
located
Beyond is the existing ecological area
and you can see the bunding which is in
in place at the moment
with Gaiden with Gaiden Beyond and you
can see the nearest Residential
Properties just where my cursor is
running along there
so
in order to give members an
understanding of how the proposal may
look in the landscape I've included a
number of photo montages
submitted by the applicant in respect of
the application
what they what they do is show the
current Baseline position and the
proposal after 20 years
So This Is A View From The Clinton Road
looking towards Fields two and one so if
I just go to the corner here just to
give an indication you can see the the
sort of far extent of Gaiden there and
just to the to the north you can see the
extent of the of the solar array
um
what I should say is members should be
aware that these plans are designed to
be viewed at a larger scale to give an
accurate represent representation
however they are considered to give a
helpful indication at this scale
of the changes that will take place
so this is the current Baseline here so
we were effectively looking at Fields
one and two
along there and what members will be
able to see there is the darker air area
there where the proposed solar panels
would be would be going
so this is
um a view close to some of the
Residential Properties to the south of
the site so
if we look in the corner there just
where my cursor is you can see
um
that's the ecological bun to the north
and there's an open area here
which is just in the foreground here of
the photographs
so what you can see again is the
Baseline
photo and then you can see it with the
solar array in situ
and again in a similar location just
moving slightly further north again you
can see the Baseline position and again
after 20 years
chairman there are a number of updates
as detailed in the update sheet
including a further consultation
response from the Lee local flood
Authority
confirming that based on the information
received from the applicants they now
raise no objection to the proposal
subject to the imposition of three
conditions and two notes
as noted in the in the update sheet I
think number three may be missing off
the conditions but there are three
conditions detailed there
chairman the application is recommended
for approval now that the lead local
flood Authority have removed their
objection thank you now thank you very
much indeed members if you had an
opportunity to read the update sheet
marvelous in that case we will call our
first speakers on this item who is our
agent Miss Susan Bell and we also have
uh representations from our applicants
who are Mary Ann Jones and Britta now
I'm sorry if I get this wrong is it
shred or shreed shreed British read
now as I understand it uh Miss Bell will
be doing the speaking and you're both
here for questions so miss Bell whenever
you're set come from ready to go you'll
have three minutes I will give you your
the 30 second warning and the way I have
for everyone else when you're
comfortable floor's yours thank you very
much I'm asking for your support and for
you to support your officer's
recommendation to approve the proposed
solar Redevelopment at Jaguar Landover
UK is in the midst of a climate
emergency declared at both a national
and local level as well as an energy
crisis climate change as we all know is
the greatest challenge facing our
society and planning plays a key role in
contributing to both mitigation and
adaptation to climate change a number of
national guidance and policy documents
highlight the need to move away from
dependents upon fossil fuels from
volatile markets and increase the
proportion of electricity generated
through renewable sources and
specifically in relation to solar the
British energy security strategy expects
Solar Development to increase five-fold
by 2035 which could potentially result
in an additional 70 gigawatts of solar
across the UK at a local level
Warwickshire County Council and
Stratford and even District Council both
declared a climate emergency in July
2019. Warwickshire is committed to
reducing greenhouse gas emissions from
areas within their direct control but
have also pledged for warcher to be Net
Zero by 2050 or sooner in addition a
Stratford and even District Council have
set the aim of the district becoming
carbon neutral by 2030. therefore in
order to support these aims renewable
energy generation to support a vital
local employer is considered to be one
of a key action at the business level
the electricity generated by the
development would support Jaguar
Landover in their transition to Common
NetZero business by 2039. therefore
there's an urgency to decarbonize Energy
System replacing fossil fuels with clean
and low-cost Technologies such as the
development at the outset and drag your
Land Rover in central undertake an
extensive site and Technology selection
process whereby alternative locations
and Technologies were considered these
Alternatives were discounted for various
reasons in our sporting documents and
the ground-mounted solar array was
considered to be more suitable for
Jaguar land Rover's current electricity
needs
there are a number of benefits
associated associated with the proposed
development including contribution
towards national and local renewable
energy and Net Zero carbon emission
targets increased energy security the
solar array would provide approximately
40 of electricity needs of Jaguar Land
Rover therefore
reducing Reliance upon fossil fuels and
reducing Demand on the National Grid as
well there is landscape enhancement
measures there's biodiversity net gain
which would allow for a 52 increase in
biodiversity units across the site
and the type of development is fully
reversible so at the end of the
operational phase the components will be
removed
as a proposed development is fully
reversible the agricultural land is not
permanently lost unlike traditional
bricks and mortar type development which
form a permanent addition to the
countryside so we agree with the
balanced assessment of the potential
effects of the development against the
benefits of the renewable energy scheme
and just to conclude that the
development would provide an opportunity
for Jaguar Landover to generate
approximately 40 of their electricity
needs through a renewable resource and
Aid in their transition to Net Zero
carbon emissions across our supply chain
products and operations by 2039 thank
you
six milliseconds over but I think I'm
going to allow that
um members do we have any questions for
any of our speakers and representatives
Council post together please
yeah thank you um so you mentioned about
the biodiversity net gain
um can you tell us a bit more about that
and are you going to achieve it and I
also want to if you can comment the
security fencing looks quite
anti-wildlife at the moment so any
um mitigations on that thank you so with
the security fencing and they'll be in
Badger Gates
um on the fencing which will be secured
through a condition in effects actual
and that will allow for the movement of
mammals and through through the site to
allow them to keep keep moving
um in terms of the biodiversity net gain
and so it's been
um it's been brought together by a
number of ecological assessments that
we've done on site and probably the main
things that we're looking at is the
implementation of Wildflower Meadows the
enhancement of the existing hedgerows
and making them thicker and taller and
and that's kind of where we get the
biodiversity units from
any other questions members Casa Mills
thanks Jim good evening
um I've just moved through the report
um
I mean there has been suggestions that
uh Jack alone lambrevi used the center
of their Proving Ground and they've said
they can't do that because of accidents
does he have a crash barrier around this
Proving Ground
to stop the I'm just
I mean but the argument is that they
can't use approval ground because it
might crash into the um
uh solar panels but as you've got a
crash barrier there anyway
to stop this
some some areas of the The Proving
Ground do have a crash barrier and some
don't just for the first sort of various
different testing so we did ask our
Engineers that very question at the
moment when we test our vehicles they
are pushed to their limits so they are
going around The Proving Ground at a
very high speed right which means that
they need larger runoff areas now if we
were to move that where put crash
barriers in in order to protect
potential solar arrays it would have
reduced the area in which the solar
arrays would be situated anyway so so it
would have reduced the area furthermore
when we
test our vehicle so I'm not an engineer
so I'm just paraphrasing our Engineers
please excuse me
um they do noise testing they do wind
variant testing and they need a flat
open area in which to do that having
putting panels in the middle of that
will disrupt the testing facility and
the ability to test the noise and the
wind
off the vehicles that we're testing so
it was suggested by the engineers they
wouldn't be optimal testing conditions
with anything in the middle of the
Proving Ground
right well fell off Mr and because I
noticed there's been lots of references
to um
um Bentley and so on but uh why is this
there's are they using their Proving
Ground well
for this
so so so it was Nissan I think was
referred to so Nissan has a test track
and we don't know the specifics of what
Nissan use on their test trap obviously
a test track and approving grounds where
we're told are very different so we are
research and development we're pushing
prototype vehicles to their absolute
limits therefore we need to be
absolutely sure uh Engineers are
completely safe so there are nothing no
barriers known to think that they can
crash into and obviously affect the
testing facility on the site Nissan We
Believe are testing autonomous vehicles
and we haven't reached out to Nissan so
we can't confirm this but it's it's
obviously a different shape track it's a
different nature and it's obviously not
prototype vehicles that we're aware of
and clearly Engineers can differ in in
opinion and our Engineers are absolutely
certain that anything in the middle of
our Proving Ground would be
it wouldn't be great for testing
um again I was just looking through the
um
um report
the um Transformers that
would there be a continued noise with
this Transformers do we know
there's a very small noise so um
design process they aim to keep those as
far away as possible from residents
um and the noise assessment hasn't
hasn't identified any any effect during
the operation so they're very very quiet
but there is maybe a small noise but
they're moved away thank you very much I
have one more below
um I've written a report that there's
the potential to export to the National
Grid under extreme weather conditions
um any idea of any percentages or how
much you like to be exported and I know
you know last year was potentially an
extreme year in terms of weather but we
never know I just wondered any any
figures around that place
and I don't have an answer to that but I
do know in my limited experience of
solar Farms that in order to
um it will be sort of 20th of June
height of Summer and it's just in case
we top out the energy on that day it has
to have somewhere to go and obviously we
don't have any battery storage facility
proposed at the moment and so that it
needs to go somewhere so it'll be a
trickle effect into the grid but I don't
have the figures it won't be a lot
Curtis next please
thank you
um
I'm just again picking up this the
comment on page 37 the existing car
Parks were not constructed for
retrofitting of carport infrastructure
well no presumably they wouldn't have
been
um but then it goes on to say that the
carport solar panels would that would be
heavily shaded by the buildings adjacent
but
I'm just looking at the car parks
on good old Google Maps
and there are very very large areas of
car park
that aren't overshadowed by any
buildings at all
so I'm just
you know that I wonder how seriously
that has been considered if not as an
alternative
as an additional means of
you know Green Cleaner electricity
because yeah there just seems to be a
lot of car Park area that isn't anywhere
near any buildings at all and so I find
that statement that uh
we obviously we have to consider the
application in front of us which is not
to put solar arrays on top of car Parks
is to put it in fields so a point share
I think we'll probably move on from that
cancer Adam next please
thank you um so I understand you uh
Jacaranda over owns the land that is
going on
um so presumably the agricultural land
is the tenant Farmer at the moment
um do you know what sort of impact this
will have to their business in terms of
the reduction of agricultural fields
that they're able to use
and just in relation to the agricultural
land and so there's the majority of the
land is grade 3B so it's not that's the
most versatile I think there's three
hectares of three so I don't know if
you've got anything to add on kind of
the business side of things
so in terms of the tenant Farm obviously
um we've consulted with the tenant
farmer I don't I don't know the figures
um he was obviously in agreement the
field is fellow at the moment
um
so I haven't really got anything else to
add on that really I don't know what the
tenant Farmers views are on it
I I'll just follow up on that I'm going
to assume on the basis that the farmer
has given an agreement doing this that
it's not going to have a significant
detrimental impact to his business is
that fair
that's a fair comment share perfect
thank you very much councilor post
together please
thank you
um so can you tell us a little bit
if there are any local benefits any
benefits to the local community so
obviously I'm thinking about
um the village of Gaiden I think in the
report I saw a mention the Gaydon green
fund
um is that you know is that being
proposed to the parish council or um if
you could
thank you so we are in discussions with
Gaiden parish council at the moment
um to help contribute to what they're
calling the gate in green fund so we we
are we are in negotiation with that
they've put a number of proposals to us
so through the pre-app and through the
application process we have obviously
been in liaison with the planning
Authority and officers have advised us
that this sits outside of the planning
application
um but obviously we want to make sure
that you know we we're good neighbors
and and we're neighborly so we are in an
ongoing conversations with Gage and
they've put a couple of proposals to us
which we hope to be able to agree but
obviously that sits outside of this
planning application as the officers
have advised
so but the village will not benefit from
any green energy from this this is all
going to go to a jlr yes in terms of
energy now the village won't be able to
benefit from the green energy but we
will obviously not be drawing on the
National Grids we'll obviously produce
in our own so obviously freeze up
capacity there's a secondary benefit
there for locals
anyone else with any questions
councilman because I'm feeling very
generous do you want to ask your fourth
question if you can remember what it was
if I can remember what it was short-term
memory loss here Mr chairman
um no not not to worry councilor Perry's
got one
just thought I'd come in chair
um
can you advise whether the benefit to
Jaguar Land Rover of uh providing 40 of
your energy source would that enable
further expansion of jlr because you are
become more self-sufficient and
therefore potentially create jobs
so this this project was solely linked
to our destination xero AIMS in terms of
becoming carbon neutral and and reducing
our carbon footprint so it wasn't
directly linked to job creation however
obviously the the better and more
Greener we are the more successful We
Believe will be as a business
um so no it wasn't directly linked to
job creation but obviously the two may
be linked in the future and it fits
within our corporate responsibility in
our corporate Direction which we want to
go in
cancer crumps taking advantage of my
generosity and come in with a question
yeah cancer cramp my favorite subject
um regarding the sax using getting 40
energy from these methods would it make
your plant more viable more cost
effective in other words is this type of
electricity cheaper than buying it from
from the greeted in as part of the
overall project
in short answer is yes it absolutely
will benefit uh that I I don't
unfortunately have the figures but
obviously it's it's a 40 cost saving
direct from our energy bills at the
moment which are obviously direct from
National Grid so we'll be
self-sufficient energy wise 40 and what
I will say is this is the first of many
uh sustainable energy options we are
looking into
um so hopefully we'll be able to bring
more in front of you and be more
sustainable in the future
marvelous I think that's it now does
anyone else want to stick up an arm no
in that case Miss belmus Jones Miss Reed
thank you very much indeed for your time
and contribution this evening
okay we'll call for our final speaker of
the evening who is councilor kettle
come on down counselor kettle
back from rustling sheep this evening
from what I understand so counselor
Kettle you know the drill
you have five minutes
uh I'll give you a 30 second warning the
same way as I have done for everyone
else use as much or as little as five
minutes as you wish whenever you're
comfortable and ready to go the floor is
yours
thank you Mr chairman
um here we are yet another solar farm
and um in in on Prime agricultural land
um and I would like to remind uh all
members of the planet committee that yes
we have a climate crisis but that is not
the only crisis we have we have a food
crisis
Ukraine has 32 million hectares of
agricultural land which is now
unproductive and is likely to be
unproductive for many years we have food
inflation as the highest component of
the cost of living standards at the
moment because
um of the impact of the Ukrainian War
I would like and I've never had this
answered I would like the planning
officers to say what is the difference
between 3A and 3B in terms of
productivity because I would remind
every member of this committee that the
criteria of three one two three four and
five were set between 1930 and and the
late 70s and amended in 1988 to
introduce 3A and 3B
what does it mean all we're told is
three B is okay to develop 3A isn't
nobody's ever given us a quantitative
analysis of y3b is acceptable to be
developed and y3a is not
so I would like somebody to demonstrate
to you the committee how poor this 3B
land is compared to what the Benchmark
which would not allow it to be developed
that to me is a perfectly reasonable
question
as opposed to saying 3B
Let It Go
um
I would also like to bring to your
attention
that were told somewhere this is fallow
land but we're told it's agricultural
land
all my life and I have lived in the
Jason Village this has been arable land
so to describe it as fallow land is
incorrect it is arable land it has grown
wheat barley oats various other herbal
crops for the last 60 something years so
let's talk about Los agricultural
productivity and the real figures
opposed to just a very very outdated
category on which it is very easy to
rely on without
factual evidence as to what value of
agricultural production we're going to
lose when we have a very significant
food crisis and very significant food
inflation and wheat is quite an
important part of our everyday diet
let's talk about employment
when solar Farms are built contractors
come in quite often from overseas
they're very good at their job they fly
in well driving with all the panels they
stick them in they disappear it is a
very technical job it is not something
that generates local employment
therefore there'll be no employment
benefit from this whatsoever
in fact there will be employment loss
because that our agricultural land will
no longer be productive agricultural
land
then I'd like to go to
um the nppg referred to on page 36 of
your report
that says authorities should encourage
the effective use of land by focusing
development on previously developed
non-agricultural land
right above this application site and
some way from the village of Gayden is
an old RAF station
with very significant runways when the
parish council and I raised with the
proposals of this application
um
why can't you put it on site they
haven't done the exercise
they have subsequently done the exercise
but having already designed what this
application would look like
to me that seems to me that looking
shutting the stable door after the horse
is bolted
we are told this site is so different
from Nissan because Nissan have less
high standards for testing I'm sure any
Nissan driver will be delighted to hear
that their cars are not properly tested
according to jlr standards
what we need to see is we need to see
empirical evidence and we haven't had it
why the considerable amount of
Brownfield land around the runways on
this site cannot be used we're told the
car Parks as well cannot be disturbed
but the car Parks built for an
employment side of over 11 000 people
that level is considerably below where
they were at their Peak as a result of
covered homeworking etc etc it would not
be beyond the width of a designer to
work out a way as can be done in a
supermarket car Parks all over the
country where they're installing these
things you don't disrupt the
supermarkets activity Mr Tesco wouldn't
want that by installing solar panels
over their car Parks why can jlr not do
exactly the same what major retailers
are doing and ensure the continuing use
of their car Parks I'm going to have to
ask you to stop there that is your five
minutes right
um members do we have any questions for
councilor Kettle please Council Dixon
cancer kettle
um what is the value of uh 28 hectares
of agricultural wheat
um
an acre should be produced about three
three and a half tons and the conversion
rate is
um something about two and a half times
so we should be producing three three
and a half six by eight tons
at about 200 tons an eight uh 200 pounds
at a time
I haven't got my calculator I'm sorry
Council Dixon
in terms of size of farm 28 hectares is
small
medium
it it is inherently errors it is quite a
small arable area compared to the UK
agricultural production
but I would say every bit counts
any other questions for cancer cattle
please cancel seraphim
cancer Kettle
would you say this is good quality
agricultural land
it is a south facing slope gently
sloping It is Well drained
um it is heavy clay
and the issue with heavy clay in 1930
was we did not have the agricultural
equipment to be able to cultivate it
properly agricultural technology has
changed Dramatics since the 1930 and
heavy Clays are now some of the most
productive arable land in the whole of
the UK it's not quite new like Ukraine
Ukraine that is a very special soil that
is almost unique
um but it is exactly what an arable
farmer would like to have generally
sloping south facing
um and the benefit of heavy Clays is
they retain water during the dry Summers
which the the clothes that we see say on
Edge Hill and the aonb cannot deliver so
this would be hybrid generally would be
high productive I know I've got exact
same soil on my farm which is very close
to the site
anyone else
no just before you go Castle I'm just
going to correct a statement that you
made earlier use in
asserted that our previous speakers had
said that Nissan had a lower standard of
uh testing they did not do that they
said they test in a different way if
you're willing to retract that I'd be
grateful but of course it's up to you
whether you wish to very happy to
correct you by you Mr chairman what I
would say is I'm sure all Automotive
manufacturers are very keen to test
their products to the best possible
ability
thank you very much
okay members do we have any put did you
sorry do you have a question for cancer
you can make your way back it's not a
question for you points of clarification
do you have on cancer Crump counselor
Harvey then please
can I refer to page 35
um and I think this is a
key centers I'd need to understand in
order to know how to assess this
application now the last sentence reads
lpa's local planning authorities are
directed to approve applications if
impacts are acceptable
um can I ask the officer what the impact
of nppf
is in this regard do I take that to be
as good as statute
law which must be followed
page 39 you said page 35 35 sorry um
which paragraph last paragraph last
sentence sorry there's about five people
shouting over the top of me here and
councilor Harvey it's going to make it
even more difficult to hear what's going
on if everyone's shouting one person at
a time please counselor Harvey could you
please say again page 35 last paragraph
last sentence
in my papers
my question is the effect
this is key to how I look at this
application if I am being directed by
the uh by the mppf to approve
applications unless the impacts are
unacceptable then my test is what what
are the aspects of this application
which I think are unacceptable to the
point I would have to refuse it
otherwise I'm being told directed is the
word that's quoted here I'm being
directed by the nppf to approve the
application is that a correct
interpretation
um yeah I think you're you're correcting
that assertion what what is effectively
saying is that there isn't a need to
justify the need for renewable or or low
carbon energy that is taken as red that
there is a need
um but what what they're saying is that
local plans are directed to approve it
unless
if impacts are or can be made acceptable
so unless you think that there is
something that outweighs that
then yes your assertion's correct
councilor Parry please
thank you can
possibly confirm a approximately the
distance to the nearest residential
property
from
the so I mean it looks fairly
significant to me
but it would just help me to understand
yards meters
um
right so I've that's the smallest number
yeah I've prepared a few measurements I
thought
this might come up if the truth be told
so
um so just giving you a few measurements
here so if I take it from the end of the
property there
to the red line boundary just a straight
line
you're looking at roughly 170 meters
[Music]
um
from property here again to the red line
you're looking at approximately 220
meters
um and then is that is that okay
marvelous Castle Mills please
thanks Mr chairman um Neil do you know
if there'll be any security lights on on
this site that's the first question
no there aren't there isn't any external
item proposed the only lighting proposed
counselor is internal in respect of the
storage facility that I mentioned and
just just a quick we went perhaps you'd
have to ask the applicant but um it's
about Badger Gates I mean that that's
you know human beings won't be able to
access this site then
they told me the wildlife won't be
stopped going in that's Badgers yes so
human beings couldn't get onto this site
through these no no I mean the intention
is for this site to be very secure I
don't think they would be looking to uh
the the deer that normally run on this
field
can't get access no okay
councilor together
so I've seen some of the objections
um there were reference to glint and
glare towards the village of gaidon do
we know whether the solar panels are not
reflective or do we will be more about
that how do we Safeguard The Village if
there is Clinton
yes they're um
but they are non-reflective as as I
understand now a glint and glare
assessment has been undertaken
um as part of the application
um you may have noted in the um in the
in the committee report that there are
um
four properties
which are potentially affected uh let me
if I can just
so
um if I this is from the an extract from
the
um from the report
so effectively there's a number of
properties that you probably were able
to see in the photograph that I showed
looking towards the The Village behind
the ecological band
so they these have all been assessed as
part of the uh of the application now
the conclusion reached that these
properties here wouldn't be impacted
upon
um primarily because of the screening
impact of the of the ecological Bond as
well
so there's four properties which have
been assessed as having a very low
impact
which is detailed in the committee
report but you're talking of less than
five minutes a day in terms of any
potential impact
um and there was another property which
is just further south and that again was
was
um it was seen as no or an insignificant
impact and no glare was predicted so it
so it has been comprehensively assessed
okay any other points clarification
before we move to the debate
open Army there's lots
hang on a second did you stick your hand
up
foreign
yep
I think I've got the answer from my
understanding of the grades but
councilor Kettle did raise a query
regarding the difference between the sub
grades of agricultural land and that
seemed to be quite a hinge of part of
his argument so he was just wondering if
there was any elaboration on
on how those differ considering they're
both within grade three from a planning
point of view whether it is literally a
line to say this is acceptable this
isn't or whether there's some more
gradient in in those grades from from
your planning point of view
German I I think councilor Adam has hit
the the nail absolutely on the head
um the advice from the government is
that grade 3A is part of best and most
versatile
and grade 3B isn't and there's no room
for us to debate or discuss that that is
the information we're given by
government that's the information we
have to act on
Casper did you put your hand Up For
Debate or point of clarification
okay in that case we're moving to debate
I'm going to let counselor Perry go
first I'm afraid cancel the Crump
thank you chair
um we've had a number of solar farm
applications come before this planning
committee
um and
a number have been fused and then
granted on appeal in my view this is
probably the best although largest one
of the largest applications to come
before us that doesn't have an impact a
major impact on local residents it
doesn't run nearby road so there isn't
um impact on drivers in terms of
distraction
we as a district are absolutely adamant
that we are trying to grow our economy
I think what we have in front of us is a
classic example of one of our major and
leading automotive manufacturers trying
to do their very best to become car as
much as they can do to become more
self-sufficient on their energy
um being able to to generate 40
of their power through green energy is a
terrific
um
ambition and achievement and we have the
power this evening to help them achieve
that and probably
um put them in a situation where they
are more competitive
um and generate more jobs and economic
growth which is utterly essential
particularly in the current cost of
living crisis so I am delighted to
propose grant for this application thank
you chair thank you very much now
Council crumb has been waiting so
patiently so councilor Crump to you
please I'm one happiest a second I've
got several points you know I've it's
been known that I'm a supporter solar
power and certainly I'd rather have a
server Farm near me than hsd but that's
another issue we declared the climate
emergency and what's important to
declaring the climate emergency when
we're not going to do it yes I accept
the food is important but you're damned
if you do dumbed if you don't and are
supportive of this 40 needs of its uh
helps towards its Target in reducing
greenhouse gas emissions again no brain
that makes sense we're helping it will
be helping maintain the UK energy
security of supply and it's noticeable
that yesterday that two coal-fired power
stations I think in Lincoln Lincolnshire
were bought out to my thoughts or or
whatever phrases
um and again we're going to create extra
it will create extra capacity of the
6000 not equivalent to 6900 Hertz which
is a certainly a significant number
um I do disagree with Council cattle and
I'll try and do it in a nice way because
we have to have one or two debates about
things
um I think it will
either maintain or maintain the
viability of both the center and the
museum
um
because it's on our brain it's reducing
its energy costs so therefore it will
make more um viable more acceptable more
competitive and we're safe gaining
safeguarding high quality jobs here
um and these jobs you know we're great
to have them in our district and I think
the residents really appreciate that
um so
um certainly in terms of the prototypes
the designs and I can understand the
need that the test track and near the
test track it is not suitable compared
to other other ones who are building
cars that uh
not prototypes or initiatives designs
um
so I think that's about me yeah I think
it will be great for the area I think
there's very few if any uh consorties
have objected and those objections have
been overcome uh with more work so I'm
slightly rumbled on but I will be uh
supporting the application and uh
second in The Proposal
thank you very much Council Mills next
please
yes thanks Richard yeah I I do have
concerns on this um that's cancer Kettle
said you know we need to grow more food
and it seems that we are carpeting
Warwickshire with uh solar Farms
um you know climate emergency not at all
costs that's that's my concern
um
we do need more
um food and we can see there's a food
sheltered at the moment in the in the
supermarkets and again Gaiden perhaps
not a planning consideration but not
getting a thing out of this not in a
light bulb
um so I've just got some concerns about
Mr chairman thank you
thank you very much Casa Adam next
please
thank you yeah um someone anticipated
counselors kettle's point of view on the
agricultural aspect which is why I
wanted to exhaust that both with the
applicant and my question is the
officers that that's certainly been done
I think from my point of view it was
there's a huge benefit that councilor
parry and Trump have outlined in in some
detail and I'm very happy to support it
um I think that it's worth noting that
obviously agriculture is an important
aspect of our local economy
um that these are not insignificant
um in both community and planning terms
but yeah I think they're certainly
overcome from my point of view so I'm
very happy to support thank you very
much councilor Curtis please
thank you
um
two things concern me about this I mean
I absolutely agree with all the comments
made in support
um and with the ambition of the
applicants to move towards greater
sources of renewable energy
but
um again just referring back to the
statement by the applicant the existing
car parts were not constructed for
retrofitting well no car park was
probably built for retrofitting when
they're when they were built
um
to say that the the solar panel the
sorry the the carport solar panels would
be heavily shaded by the buildings
adjacent well three of the very large
car Parks have no buildings in them at
all
and the remaining I'm I'm sorry chair
you're going to say we're looking at the
application in front of this I do need
you to make this relevant to the
application which is absolutely relevant
because the statement saying that
they've looked at these Alternatives and
they're not
um they're not viable is relevant to
this application because this is a
statement in support of this application
and I'm contesting the the veracity of
the statement so it if if this statement
in support is can be challenged and I
think if that statement wasn't there
would it materially change your opinion
on the application yes it would
because I
I think looking at the overall area of
the car Parks roughly it's not that
dissimilar to the area of agricultural
land that's being proposed
it is not correct in my view looking at
this to say that the um the car parks
are all going to be over are going to be
overshadowed significantly by buildings
that is simply not the case and I'm not
happy to support an application that in
my view has statements in it that are
demonstrably inaccurate
and also my other concern is the number
of
conditions on this
um you know would we be happy that all
of those conditions
um will be actually met but I say I'm
not happy to support an application
whether it's patently a misleading
statement supporting it
cancer seraphin
a good job
I'm not against solar panels
and I've always said
that we shouldn't be swallowing up
agricultural land because every bit adds
up to a lot
now I've looked on Google Maps and I
agree with cancer Curtis
the area of car parks and I've always
supported that
solar panels should be over large area
of car parks where the supermarkets or
even this so I can't support this
application because of loss of
agricultural land
Council Dixon please
thank you chairman I am supporting this
application and I take
some sort of comfort from the comment at
the top of page 38. whereby jlr have
confirmed that they are exploring
options for solar carports with electric
vehicle charging facilities for future
development so it can't the car Parks
aren't available now because as far as
jlr are concerned there's insufficient
space to generate the amount of
electricity that the ground base units
will provide but nevertheless there's
the opportunity and they are looking at
it it says here for something in the
future and therefore I'm supporting this
recommendation for ground
can you turn your microphone off because
it's interferes sorry counselor thank
you
thank you very much
um I don't think I can match the
eloquence of particularly councilor
Parry in setting out the case for this
particular application although as I
understand it who is making the
application is is not a planning matter
it's not it's not relevant despite the
merits of jlr but my point is quite
simple we are directed by the mppf to
approve unless there are impacts of The
Proposal which are unacceptable or can't
be mitigated I haven't heard any uh
objections of the impact that are an
unacceptable or car to be mitigated and
therefore are happily are going to
support the proposal to approve
thank you very much you thank you very
much Council post Gala please
yes so I remind you to support the
application as well and what I would say
that I would have liked to see direct
Community benefits for for the local
community and you said that you will
come back with farther um you know
renewable energy schemes and I really
would like you to think about that and
to make sure that the community will
benefit directly because we need to
bring a residence with us through this
so I hope that could be a thought
um for the future
um yes and and also I would like to see
a condition for the security fans that
will allow Wildlife into um you know in
into the into the
array solar array thank you
thank you very much Council Mills please
it just staple outside
um yeah I thought they could have uh put
this on their land the existing land at
the moment
um but obviously it costs twice as much
to do digging up their car parks and put
the um
cables in and so on so they've gone for
a cheaper option that's that's image
chairman I think
okay I I'm just gonna address that point
because it's I'm finding it quite
frustrating that we're talking about
something that they could or you feel
should have happened but the reality is
that's not what we're looking at what
we're looking at is an application for a
solar array on these fields whether
they've made a business decision to do
it another way is irrelevant we have to
look at the planning reasons uh um as
I've been set out and I wholeheartedly
agree with the comments that have been
made by both councilor parry and
councilor Harvey and a number of other
councils this evening we do have a
proposal to Grant it has been seconded
in line with the office recommendation
so we're going to move to a vote please
can I have a show of hands for those in
favor of granting please
nine and those against please
committee therefore resolves to Grant
application
2203361 ful Jaguar Land Rover and Gaiden
we have one final item members which is
application reference
2200103 ful 14 Waterside in
stratford-upon-avon our presenter
conference is once again in the old
Hempstead so Neil as soon as you're
ready over to you
I've been good
so thank you chair
um
the site location in Stratford is shown
on the plan there so if we just go into
a bit more
detail yeah
so it's just where the uh where the
cursor is there on water side and the
proposals for change of use of a
community from a community used to
residential use which seeks to reverse a
previous permission so the district
council application and hence why it's
being presented to to committee today
so the flat was previously used as a
drop-in facility for homeless people
which has now moved to the new Fred
winter Center in Stratford and the
property will be used as one of the
District Council next step properties
which means that someone who used to be
in temporary accommodation would be
placed in the property
so
just giving members
um photograph of where we are so
it's effectively above the public
conveniences on Waterside and the area
is just in there so it's a first floor
flat so it's the front elevation
the rear elevation with the axis going
up the steps there
and the internal layout which is
effectively a one bed flat
chairman there are two updates as
detailed in the update sheet on point of
clarification and chairman the
application is recommended for approval
as detailed in the committee report
thank you
now thank you very much indeed we have
no speakers on this item so does anyone
have any points that they want
clarifying
let's move into debates who would like
to kick us off councilor Crump was in
first
yeah thank you Mr chairman I'm happy to
propose this this was discussed briefly
over and scrutiny about the need for the
next step the moving on and there was a
need for this demonstrated didn't watch
the ball need for this so I'm happy to
support and propose grunting the
application thank you very much
councilor Adam next please thank you
very happy second Council Harvey Council
Adam beat me to it anyone else can I
show everyone's in favor of granting
unanimous committee therefore resolves
to Grant application
2200103 ful 14 a Waterside do we have
any urgent business please give her a
note in that case ladies and gents boys
and girls thank you very much see you
next week